comédien chouchou du public québécois le
talent exceptionnel de Michel Côté s'est
révélé dessiné après décennies au cours
de ces 50 ans de carrière le théâtre
c'était pas sûr de gagner ma vie mais je
te sur des messages j'ai pris le risque
au sein de la troupe Les voyagesment et
l'état des trois gars de Brou présenté
en grande première en mars 1979 la pièce
obtiendra le record mondial de longévité
pour une production jouée avec la main
distribution pendant près de 40 ans
en 1989 il marque les esprits dans
Cruising Bar une comédie où il incarne
quatre hommes à la recherche de l'amour
ça me faisait peur mais je pouvais pas
penser à côté de des filles comme ça que
tu aimes la péter comme il faut une fois
dans la petite vie il a été inoubliable
Jean-Loup vous ne serez pas croire vous
autres que vous captez pas sur mes bases
mais Michel Côté était plus sérieux dans
la série omerta de lubione où il était
Pierre Gauthier un enquêteur d'une
escouade de lutte contre le crime
organisé si jamais il y a une autre de
vos gars qui touche à un cheveu de ma
fille
en 2006 Michel potier a reçu un prix
jetera et un prix Génie pour son rôle
dans le film crazy de Jean-Marc Vallet
un personnage auquel il était resté
attaché excuse-moi
je te dis
toujours au cinéma on a vu Michel Côté
dans d'autres succès dont de faire un
clic dans fichier entre ciel et terre et
l'interprété avec bienveillance le rôle
du commandant Robert Piché
attaché à ses origines il avait été très
ému lorsque sa ville natale a baptisé
une salle de spectacle à son nom à
chaque fois que je leur ai mis à
Montréal ma mère le nez dans du salon
qui a pleuré et moi aussi en 2017 la
mouture originale de la pièce Brooke
tire sa révérence après avoir donné 3322
représentations en 38 ans sans le savoir
Michel Côté faisait ses adieux à la
scène de penser que j'aurais pu jamais
pointu ça me fait quelque chose ça me
fait quelque chose
qu'on a eu sur scène
à jouer avec vos autres mon but d'envie
ça a jamais été d'être une vedette ça a
été d'être heureux mon but être heureux
c'est un cliché tout le monde le dit
mais c'est vrai
[Musique]